because that string happens to be in the 743 hemming code but not in its duol one final comment here is that we often
don't actually care all that much about what vectors in our code spaces look like because we generally don't need to know this in order to use the
codes so if this explanation wasn't clear it's really not something to worry about too much but it is certainly
natural to ask what vectors in code spaces of CSS codes look like and this description provides an answer to that
question next we'll discuss a specific CSS code known as the Torah code which is an example of something known as a
topological quantum error correcting code this code was discovered by Alexa kayv in
1997 in fact the Torah code isn't a single code but rather it's a family of codes one for each positive integer at
least two these codes possess some Key Properties the first key property is
that all of the stabilizer generators have low weight as poly operations in particular they're all going to have
weight four and this is good because it means that each of the stabilizer generator measurements doesn't need to
involve too many cubits sometimes people speak of quantum ldpc codes or Quantum low density parity
check codes and this is what is meant by this term where in this case low means four so the Tor code is an example of a
Quantum ldpc Code the Tor code also has what's called geometric locality which means that not
only do the stabilizer generators have low weight but it's also possible to arrange the cubits spatially so that
each of the stabilizer generator measurements only involves cubits that are close together which makes these measurements easier to implement in
principle and finally these codes have large distance so they can tolerate a relatively High rate of
Errors here's how these codes work first let capital L be a positive
integer that's at least two and consider an L by L lattice with so-called periodic IC
boundaries for example here's an L by L lce for Lal 8 and notice that the lines
on the right and on the bottom are dotted lines and the idea here is that we want to think about the dotted line on the right as being the same line as
the line on the left and similarly the dotted line on the bottom is the same line as the one on
top so if we actually wanted to realize this sort of configuration physically we'd need three
dimensions in particular we could form a cylinder by first matching up the left and right sides and then bend the
cylinder around so that the circles at the ends which used to be the top and bottom edges of the lattice meet or you
could match up the top and bottom first and then the sides it works both ways and it doesn't matter which way you do it for the sake of this
discussion what we get is a Taurus or in other words a donut although thinking about it as an inner tube of a tire is
perhaps a better image to have in mind because this isn't aoft the lattice has actually become just the surface of a
Taurus and this is where the name Torah code comes from the way that you can move around on
a Taurus like this assuming that you're able to move between adjacent points on the lattice will likely be familiar to people that have played old school video
games where if you move off the top edge of the screen you emerge in the bottom and likewise for the left and right edges of the
screen and for the most part this is the way that I'll describe this lattice as a oos to talking specifically about a
Taurus in a three-dimensional space next we imagine that cubits are
placed on the edges of the lattice as is Illustrated here on the screen where cubits are indicated by solid blue
circles notice by the way that the cubits that are placed on the dotted lines aren't solid and that's because we've already represented those cubits
either by the ones along the top or the left hand side keeping in mind that the lines on the top and the left are exactly the same lines as the ones
indicated by the dotted lines on the bottom and the right and so if we count up all of these cubits we get 2 * l^ 2 cubits and one
way to see that is to observe that we get l s cubits on horizontal edges and L squar cubits on vertical
edges so that's the layout of our cubits and to describe the Tor code itself we just need to describe the stabilizer
generators and there are two types of them first we have Z stabilizer generators
and these correspond to tiles or pletes in the figure and second we have X stabilizer
generators and these correspond to vertices in the figure so for example here's one
stabilizer generator meaning that we're tensoring together one poly Z operation for each of the cubits that are touching this tile along with identity matrices
on all the other cubits and that gives us a weight for poly operation and here's an example of an X
stabilizer generator where we have poly X matrices acting on the four cubits incident to this vertex along with
identity matrices on all of the other cubits so once again it's a weight for poly operation it's important that for both
of these types of stabilizer generators we include the ones that wrap around at the periodic boundaries and here's an example of an x- stabilizer generator
that does this now in order to get a valid stabilizer code we need the stabilizer
erators to commute the Z stabilizer generators all commute with one another because Z commutes with itself and the identity
commutes with everything and likewise for the X stabilizer generators it's also clear that a z stabilizer generator and an x-
stabilizer generator commute when they act non-trivially on disjoint sets of cubits like for the two generators that are shown
here the remaining possibility is that a z stabilizer generator and an X stabilizer generator overlap and
whenever that happens it's always two c on which they overlap and so the stabilizer generators commute because ZZ
and xx commute now this is not a minimal set of stabilizer generators in particular if we multiply
all of the Z stabilizer generators together we get the identity because every Cubit gets multiplied by z twice
once for each of the tiles that touches the Cubit that means that multiplying all of the Z stabilizer generators together
except for one of them gives us that last one so they're not independent but if we remove any one of them we will get
an independent set and the same is true for the X stabilizer generators so we can remove one of each
and it doesn't matter which ones we remove and that leaves l^2 minus one stabilizer generators of each type to be
clear about this and this is something that I alluded to in the previous lesson we actually do care about all of these stabilizer generators and in a strictly
operational sense we won't actually pick one of each type to ignore but but for the sake of analyzing the code we can
imagine that one stabilizer generator of each type has been removed so that we get a minimal generating set keeping in